on 8 news now it's 544 on your Thursday
morning look it's bat Major League
Baseball the first major American pro
sports team pro sports to start playing
no offense to Major League Soccer so
tonight the defending World Series
champs the Washington Nationals taking
on the New York Yankees first pitch
being thrown up at dr. Anthony pouchy no
fans at any of the games throughout the
60 game season they're going to be
playing recorded crowd noise cardboard
cutouts of fans at some stadiums for
baseball managers no lineup card
exchanges at home plate no arguing with
the UMP players aren't supposed to spit
players on the other teams will be
tested for coronavirus multiple times a
week and even with the limited schedule
some clubs still have to travel do
coronavirus hotspots like Arizona
California Texas by the way there is
another game tonight featuring the Los
Angeles Dodgers hosting their
cross-state rivals the San Francisco
Giants - a minor league baseball sort of
you know the Las Vegas ballpark been
talking about those behind the scenes
tours while they're adding more they're
available every Friday now through
August 21st you get to go behind the
scenes you get to go on the field in the
club houses even up to the VIP level the
tickets are just ten bucks
however the tour groups are limited to
ten people per group Alex all right Nate
the NFL is not only keeping teams safe
but also fans as well fans will be
required to wear masks at all games this
upcoming season right now the NFL does
not have a legal wide policy on hosting
fans but some teams do plan to host a
limited amount season will kick off on
September 10th Chuck all right so we'll
get back to John here in a second but
the Las Vegas Golden Knights are about
to get a new rival today's Seattle's NHL
franchise is announcing its name logo
and colors the NHL posted a video to
Twitter last night which seems to
suggest a nautical theme
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so Kraken whales seals Sakai and totems
have their old trademarked by the
ownership group Seattle was awarded a
team back in 2018 they will start to
play next year plenty of time for Golden
Knights fans to prepare for their new
rivals so it is exciting to see baseball
coming back and just to be talking about
sports again eight oh I'm very excited
about it weird
of course I'm I'm wearing my Dodger oh
yeah both times you are ready to go and
they play tonight yeah they're playing
the San Francisco Giants tonight Clayton
Kershaw going against Johnny Cueto and I
know sherry is a big Giants fan yes so
we have our own little rivalry going but
I think the the good news is we're
talking is that sports are back sherry
yes we are so glad the only thing is our
tetra is not gonna play this year Posey
I have to pass somebody at physical
therapy the other day and she had on a
Giants outfit and I go hey go Giants and
she was like what you're a Giants fan we
talked about the Giants for 20 minutes